[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact have you ever wished you
could have a brain like Albert Einstein
evidently someone else wanted his brain
so much they stole it before the famous
physicists died in 1955 at the age of 76
he gave specific instructions he wanted
to be cremated but the New Jersey
pathologist dr. Thomas Harvey who
performed the autopsy thought it would
be a shame to incinerate such a
legendary brain so without the family's
permission
Harvey decided to remove and save
Einstein's brain in the name of
scientific research for decades dr.
Harvey kept the genius's brain in a
glass jar under a beer cooler
eventually he dissected a small part of
Einstein's brain to create a thousand
microscopic slide samples of the tissue
to send to other brain researchers all
over the world those scientists who
examine the brain concluded it wasn't
normal while Einstein s brain weighed
10% less than the brain of an average
adult male yet the region of the brain
that processes mathematical and spatial
reasoning was 15% larger than an average
brain Einstein's brain also lacked the
normal degenerative changes you'd find
in a 76 year old still the source of
Einstein's genius remains a mystery dr.
Harvey eventually donated the remainder
of Einstein's brain to the pathology
department at Princeton hospital one
thing we can assure you Einstein's brain
is not thinking right now but the Bible
says it will think again in the future
stay with his friends we're going to
learn more on this edition of bible
answers why
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
and my name is john ross good evening
friends and pastor Doug let's start the
program with prayer dear father in
heaven once again we are grateful that
we have this opportunity to open up your
word and study together and we do ask
your blessing upon this program be with
those who are listening some who are
driving in their cars others who are at
home and we just pray Lord that you
guide all of us into a clearer
understanding of your word thank you for
this opportunity in Jesus name Amen amen
well pastor day I'm sure everybody at
some point has thought to themselves
especially in school especially kids man
I wish I could be cleverer than I am I
wish I was as clever as Einstein and a
lot of folks have wondered well what was
it that he had was he somehow his mind
somehow different than most people kind
of interesting this little bit of
scientific study they've done on his
brain first of all somebody who stole
his brain and then did some further
research yeah he was a very interesting
character you know some people say that
he didn't even talk until he was four
and then when he went to school they
kicked him out of several schools
because they said he can't learn
well he was just so far ahead his mind
was daydreaming about the physics of the
universe and kids are you know doing
Plato or whatever they did back then
yeah very a very interesting character
he'd frequently forget very basic things
like what was my address do you know
when he was thinking he was always
thinking so far outside the box with the
physics of the universe and some people
say you know you know Einstein was a
genius and he was an atheist that is
categorically not true in fact he said
many times my God created laws his
universe is not ruled by wishful
thinking but by immutable laws the
divine reveals itself in the physical
world everyone who is seriously involved
in the pursuit of science becomes
convinced that a spirit is manifest in
the laws of the universe
a spirit vastly superior to that of man
yeah he certainly saw that there was the
hand of the Divine in the created
universe and you know I mentioned that
his brain is not thinking now because
the Bible is pretty clear in
Ecclesiastes chapter 9 it says the
living know they'll die but the dead
don't know anything and Bible tells us
in Psalm 146 that when a man dies his
breath goes forth and that very day his
thoughts perish but will in Steiner Inc
again he will saved or lost he'll think
again because the Bible tells us jesus
said in John chapter 10 the hour is
coming in which all that are in their
graves will hear his voice and come
forth there is a resurrection there is a
resurrection of the just and there's a
resurrection of the Lost and one is the
first resurrection of the saved and then
there is the second resurrection
revelation 20 talks about the lost of
all ages and so everybody is going to
think again at some point and give an
answer for the things had done in their
life unlike what some people and even
some churches teach the people who die
are not walking around haunting anybody
in this world and of course we're at
that time of year when people are
decorating their yards with ghosts and
tombstones and skeletons and and all the
trappings of death
folks finds a little creepy but living
though they'll die dead don't know
anything and if you'd like to know more
about what the Bible says the state of
man is between death and the
resurrection we have a free offer we I
think I've only offered this one week
before it's sort of a premium offer
beautifully illustrated magazine that
talks about this the magazine is called
the afterlife mystery and has passed
that I mention it's not something to be
are able to offer every week but we are
offering it as a free resource for
anyone who'd call and ask again the
magazine is called the afterlife mystery
and the subtitle is decoding death hell
and eternal life we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks the
number you need to call to ask for this
free offer is eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven that is our
resource phone line again 800 eight
three five six seven four seven and you
want to ask for the magazine called the
afterlife and mystery and we'll be happy
to send that out to anyone who calls and
asks if you have a Bible question our
phone lines are open looks like we have
just a couple lines still available good
time to call in with your Bible question
the number is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven again the phone line here
to the studio 804 6 3 7 2 97 our first
caller this evening is knower listening
in Illinois Noah welcome to the program
thank you for having me I want to wish
you guys a happy Reformation day which
will be Thursday that's right my
question is why do you Christians allow
their kids to play in that play
participate in Halloween when
ecclesiastics 95 and first Thessalonians
talk about the state of the Dead and how
Halloween has like zombies and all that
have you seen you know I put a post on
the amazing Zach's Facebook page it's
got like 450 thousand views so far where
I talk about Halloween you may want to
take a peek at that and where we I give
a little bit of the history of Halloween
and I basically say that I don't think
it's biblical for are appropriate for
Christians who you know there's a lot of
good holidays where we talk about
Thanksgiving that's great
not everything from culture is bad but
Halloween is one that has so many evil
trappings of death and witches and
zombies and seances and the Bible says
avoid the works of darkness witches are
condemned in the Bible mediums or
spiritists that communicate with the
dead are condemned in the Bible and so
why would a Christian want to
participate in then I know that the kids
you know they they love to dress up and
go out and trick-or-treat but I think
it's good to teach your kids that there
are some overriding principles as a
Christian where you you have to be
different it's not wrong to tell them
look you're gonna have to stand up for
your faith and then give reasons why so
yeah I would agree that it's not
appropriate for Christians to
participate in Halloween now of course
the verse that you referring to Noah is
Ecclesiastes chapter 9 verse 5 and we
mentioned this at the beginning of the
program it's an important verse many are
wondering well can the dead
interact with the living please ask
these nine five says for the living know
that they shall die but the dead know
not anything now they have any more
reward for their memory of them is
forgotten so the dead are as the Bible
describes it in a condition of sleep a
dreamless sleep the very next conscious
thought is the resurrection for the
righteous that's the second coming for
the wicked it's the second resurrection
at the end of the 1,000 years yeah I
think no would probably enjoy our
magazine yes and that is a free offer
for today it's called the afterlife
mystery and we'll be able to send this
to anyone who calls and asks the number
is 883 five six seven four seven and
again asked for our free offer called
the afterlife mystery the subject of
death and hell and eternal life it's all
contained in that magazine amazing facts
offer some of the best Christian
resources for all ages
we help our products will enrich your
life and your walk with the Lord
dad's a subject everyone thinks about
but no one enjoys talking about is there
life after death
the afterlife mystery is a brand new
sharing magazine that answers all your
questions get yours today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767 sigh don't think he was
even referring to pagan prophets because
the Jews believed every pagan prophet
was false
he said there's gonna be false prophets
among you just like there were false
prophets in Israel from the time of
Christ's at the time of Jeremiah and
many before and after so there's gonna
be false prophets that claim to be
believers in Christ that are gonna
deceive many and we see that today some
of them have ended up in jail you know
so yes because I mean it's a sub
question because preacher at my church I
love
sermons and it seems like he's inspired
by his holy spirit and everything but
what she does at the back not everybody
likes well the main thing is you know if
a if a person there are tests in the
Bible of a true and a false prophet now
don't we have a lesson on that it's in
our lesson on psychics and astrologers
that's right it's called does God
inspire astrologists and psychics and it
actually lists the tests for a true
prophet and it's the biblical principles
and of course we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who wants to learn more
and it's the important subject jesus
warned us of these false prophets in the
last days so you can just ask for our
study guide called does God inspire
astrologists and psychics and the number
to call again is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and
we'll be happy to send that study got
out on profits to anyone who calls and
asks well thank you for your call our
next hole of the behaved is Lucy
listening in South Carolina
Lucy welcome to the program good thank
you for calling thank you and your
question so who replaced Lucifer when he
was cast out and he became the devil you
know
the Bible does not give a name the
there's only two angels were that are
specifically named in the Bible you've
got well Lucifer is the Light Bearer
sometimes called Satan and it says you
are that covering cherub talks about
Gabriel the word Gabriel means man of
God now when it talks about Michael in
the Bible the word Michael is believed
to be what they would call it
christophany whenever whenever Jesus
appeared prior to the Incarnation he
appeared under the name Michael or the
angel of the Lord certainly he didn't
you know Jesus is eternal God some of
wonder did Gabriel take Lucifer's place
we don't know the Bible does not say
specifically okay yeah I'm sure that
he's never you know God's not holding a
seat for him as though he's gonna get it
back so I'm sure whoever was next in
line there's there's some kind of order
in the Bible it seems to say there's a
order or rank among the Angels talks
about the principalities and powers and
it seems that a
suggests that both God's angels and even
Satan's angels there's some organization
and structure okay thank you so I don't
know who is next in line the vice vice
Angel got promoted huh all right he
thinks great question Lucy appreciate
you know it does appear that Gabriel
seems to play a very important role he
read about Gabriel who appears to
Zacharias I'm just thinking about the
story in Zechariah with the angel where
Zechariah asked well how do I know these
things and Gabriel says why I'm the
angel that stands in the presence of God
that's right so it appears as though
he's an angel of whole that holds a high
position maybe in the highest yeah next
caller that we have is let's see Michael
is listening in Michigan Michael welcome
to the program thank you gentlemen thank
you both I just want to say real quick
for a quick question is about
predestination all right you want to
know what is does it exist or what does
it mean thank you for asking that it's
actually does it even exist and I know
that Paul refers to it in Romans 8 and I
was arguing with a buddy I'm not really
arguing but we're having a great
conversation about it and he ended up
using John 3 I believe five and six it's
about like how the wind when it's of
Nicodemus talking to Jesus so you know
the word predestination is used in the
Bible the big challenge is not is it in
the Bible the big challenge is what does
it mean or some have interpreted it to
mean that God decided without the choice
of man God decided who he's going to
save and who he's not going to save and
that Jesus I think this is what Calvin
taught Jesus only died for those who
would ultimately be saved but I don't
find that in the Bible I find the Bible
saying that God does still respect the
free choice and will of man that
whosoever will let him come and take the
water of life freely and even John 3:16
that whosoever believes in Him why would
God say that we don't have a choice or a
will if God has pre-programmed us to
love him if he's pre-programmed us to
either be saved or lost why would God
pre-programmed creatures to
sin and then punish them for sinning he
almost then becomes an accomplice in
that sense yeah he is he has been didn't
exactly go yeah going I'm of the opinion
I would fall in the category I think
pastor Ross as well of like John Wesley
who believed that we do have a free
choice that God has chosen that he wants
everyone saved you know many are called
but if you respond to the call that's
racist fewer chosen it's a deep subject
it's Christians have been battling over
this for millennia yeah there is a
little confusion in particularly
enrollments where you read a verse for
example in Romans chapter 9 verse 13
where Paul quotes the Old Testament and
says Jacob I've loved me so I've hated
and some have wondered well is this some
sort of a predestination well I think
it's clear that God did choose Israel to
be the nation through whom the Messiah
would come and I wasn't because of any
inherent goodness in the Israelites but
God chose them and when Paul is talking
about this idea of predestination
enrollments he's not referring to an
individual choice rather he's referring
to the fact that God chose Israel to be
the nation through whom he was to work
so it's not an individual type of thing
but rather it's referring to the people
as a whole the nation as a whole it was
through the Jews that the Messiah would
come that was an arbitrary choice made
by God that through Abraham's seed the
Messiah would be born
yeah when Paul says I've I've chosen
Jacob and not Esau he's quoting the Old
Testament where they're referring to the
nations of Israel and Edom Esau was
carnally minded he wanted the physical
birth birth right and Jacob one of the
spiritual ones so God said look Jacob is
hungry for the blessing the spiritual
blessing Esau was currently minded so I
chose Jacob ultimately God's choice was
still based on the choice of the
ancestors okay
okay isn't it Peter that also said that
Paul had to be like carefully read and
understood exactly yeah Peter 2nd Peter
chapter 3 said our beloved brother Paul
says some things that are hard to endure
today you notice it never says you got
to be struggles understand James he's
real easy and even Peter is easy but
I was pretty deep that's what education
does t it makes you complicated
Paul was probably the most educated but
yeah he said the most profound things a
good question you know we do have a book
that deals with the subject of
predestination and it's called can a
save man she used to be lost if you'd
like to receive a free copy of the book
the number to call for that is at eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and again you can ask for the book
can I saved man choose to be lost and
we'll be happy to send this to anyone
who has a question about the subject and
if you have a Bible question I would
like to get your question on the program
there's still a good time to call the
number is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven and that of course
will bring you here to the studio that's
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven we still got a good dough I
don't know thirty five minutes of taking
your calls and giving Bible answers so
give us a call 800 four six three seven
two nine seven did you know amazing
backs has a free Bible school that you
can do from the comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons to aid in your study of
God's words sign up today for this free
Bible study course by calling 184 four
two one five seven thousand that's one
eight four four two one five seven
thousand four life-changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore calm or
call one eight hundred five three eight
seven two seven five we've got Jacob
listening in Boise Idaho take a welcome
to the program thank you for having me I
have a question so I struggle with
smoking
I spoke seriously like pack and a half
two packs a day and it's gonna come to a
time where my health is gonna decline
but I tried tuning gum I tried doing all
that stuff and so I know I'm weak and I
have to rather forgive me I'm weak mm-hm
but I asked him to intercede on my
behalf just take it away just take it
away from me and I know he's asking you
shall receive how come he isn't just
taking it away yet well I don't know but
you're talking to an ex-smoker
I understand it is very hard summer said
it can be as hard as getting off heroin
you know person you can smoke a
cigarette you can have a Nutella
in conversation with them but the
addiction physically is it can be pretty
serious but let me tell you it's like
Mark Twain said quitting smoking is easy
I've done it a hundred times
stain quit is the hard thing now I quit
several times before I quit for good and
praise the Lord I have not had a
cigarette in 40-something years now but
I know it's a struggle and you got to
keep at it and finally you're gonna get
to the point where you you know you're
just broken and you say Lord I don't
ever want to smoke another one that's
some people do it several ways right and
for anyone out there that's in this
category and another many and right now
there's a lot of people addicted to
vaping it's not just the old fashioned
cigarettes but there's there's a few
things you can do one is God can take it
away cold turkey I've seen that happen
sometimes there's a struggle but it gets
easier every day and every week that
you're off it until pretty soon you
don't think about it anymore which is
what happened to me I've seen people say
I'm gonna see if I can go and cut my
cigarette intake in half knew you're
smoking two packs today cut it in half
and the way to we cut that in half and
then they cut that in half and you try
to taper like that now some people that
doesn't work for most people but I've
met people that it worked for they just
kept tapering I knew guys smoke one
cigarette a day that's all he did it's
one cigarette a day I thought why smoke
but anyway you can quit you can be free
and if it's okay with you Jacob I'd like
to have a quick prayer with you
before we sign you off is that all right
yeah I just got goose bumps on my
shoulders when you said that so
definitely yes all right let me have a
quick prayer with you father in heaven
we just want to pray for Jacob and many
like him that are struggling with an
addiction like smoking and we know that
Jesus came to set the campus free that
you are able to break the chains we
believe greater is He that is in us than
he that is in the world and so I pray
you'll remove the the desire and I
should temptation come give him the
strength you promised we won't be
tempted above what above what we're able
to bear but you'll provide a way of
escape so just give him wisdom how he
can keep himself preoccupied and be free
of this
costly addiction that's also costing his
health and we thank you and ask in Jesus
name Amen
all right Jacob hey we'll pray that you
can be free of that and we got a book
we'd like to send you that I think
you'll find encouraging it's called the
power of a positive no ask for that book
the power of a positive no we'll send
you a free copy the number to coal for
that is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and again asked for
the book called the power of a positive
no and Jacob this is for you or anyone
wanting to gain the victory over some
temptation the power of a positive Noah
and you know past that I got notice we
do have another book that might be
helpful it's called tips to resisting
temptation that's got some practical
biblical principles in there and we can
send that as well just call and ask for
the book tips for resisting temptation
the number again is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven next
caller that we have is let's see Esther
in Southern California and so welcome to
the program thank you hi first of all I
like to tell Jacob that I will be
praying for him from California will
think and I wish him well bless your her
pastor Bachelor my question is how many
angels which was each individual person
assigned we can speculate a little bit
there is a verse where Jesus said their
angels do always behold and that's in
Matthew 18 10 take heed that you do not
spot despise one of these little ones
for I saying to you that in heaven their
angels always see the face of my father
who is in heaven and when he says
they're angels it's like a possessive
term it means that these children all
have a guardian angel assigned whether
it's one angel some have has said you
know Jesus tells us what Matthew twelve
every idle word we speak will give an
account of in the judgment and some of
wonder do we have a recording angel plus
a guardian angel or if a person is under
special temptation does God send more
than one angel to protect them from
Lucifer's demons and minions that are
there we don't know but I do believe
that every person has at least one
guardian angel and there may be some
high-profile people that have more than
one when you got any thoughts on that
pastor
you know I'm just looking at a couple of
other references and it is interesting
that angels do sometimes seem to connect
to an individual I'm just thinking in
Acts chapter 5 you have the story of an
angel that came and rescued Peter out of
prison and in Acts chapter 5:19 it talks
about this angel that came by night and
opened the prison doors and it almost
gives the Saints that this angel knew
Peter very well and was there to protect
and enhance the prayers of those who are
praying so yeah there's many examples of
angels being involved in saving people
there's also one other verse I'm
thinking of that might be plural is it
Psalm 91 where it says he will give his
angels charge over thee to keep you in
all your ways and then there's another
verse and I can't pass her off might
find it but it's called the angel of the
lord encamps round about those that fear
him and delivers them yea Psalms 34 7
yeah so definitely guardian angels I
feel better just talking about it so
thanks for asking that question we
appreciated Esther we're coming up on a
break now so we're gonna be taking lots
more calls but that's up to you friends
call them with your questions we'll be
right back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols chart and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five three eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five DT no amazing fax has a free Bible
school that you can do from the comfort
of your own home it includes twenty
seven beautifully illustrated study
lessons to aid in your study of God's
Word sign up today for this free Bible
study course by calling 1-800 for two
hundred fifty seven thousand that's one
eight four four two one five seven
thousand
[Music]
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 and I were
just saying we have phone calls are a
little light tonight and it occurred to
us well we got two million people in
California with no power that's
affecting charging their cell phones or
what's going on here but we are having
some serious fires and a lot of wind so
that PG&E is turned off the power pastor
Ross has no power at home that's right
so we're gonna go to ours tonight with
Bible question the darkness up there we
go power here all right who's next in
line all right we've got Edie listening
in Chicago and welcome to the program
hey guys I love you both thank you for
taking my call oh thank you I have a
quick question for you I was nominated
head elder of my church this would be my
third year but this time I decided not
to accept the role because they
nominated two female elders and I have
found no evidence in the Bible that that
was right so my question is if I did
wrong by not accepting it because again
I don't believe there's any vital
evidence for that well that's a good
question first of all I would agree with
you
that there is no Bible example I should
back up elder Bishop pastor were all the
same in the Bible a few years ago I was
part of a study group at a university to
find out is there a difference between
pastor elder Bishop and they're all the
same in the Bible there were apostles
you might have evangelist yeah deacons
and then there were the pastors of the
elders of the church they were pretty
much the same thing there were the
overseers there's no example in the
Bible of a woman being ordained in any
of those capacities or being called
matter of fact one of the criteria is it
says that an elder must be the husband
of one wife it says it also about deacon
while there's plenty of roles in the
Bible of women in ministry even as
prophetess there's no example of a woman
serving as a priest apostle pastor in
the Bible if your church is doing
something that you have an issue with of
course you would want to appeal whether
that means that you should not serve
because they're doing something wrong I
you know I the Holy Spirit's gonna have
to ask you that you know there are cases
where a church family may make some
unbiblical decisions their varying
degrees of unbiblical decisions and I
you know I want to be careful not to be
your conscience on that and because I
don't know what you know how the Lord's
leading you it might have been important
for you to make a statement that you
know you needed to stand like that I go
to China and so many of the churches in
China the men can't attend because they
have to work six days a week I've worked
with women pastors now they weren't
ordained necessarily but the women are
taking a leading role in organizing the
churches there and so while I might not
always agree we work together and had
some successful meetings I hope I'm
making sense where I might be rambling
no you're making sense
can I ask a follow-up question regarding
the same thing sure
so the thought that comes to my mind is
okay you know what maybe maybe they can
do whatever they want and so I think
anybody can do my role I meaning it's
not that they need me
typically to be the head elder I think I
bring some good things to the table but
it's not necessarily me that they need
and then I keep wondering if there's a
satanic party you know just to get me
out of the way
should I stay I don't know yeah that's
the thing you know I would really may
have already given an answer and dealt
with it and they could be water under
the bridge if you're still grappling
with it I'd ask them for a few days to
give an answer and then then pray about
it and you know if you're gonna be
uncomfortable working with a lady elder
and she's gonna feel that that tension
then you might you know just say you
know it probably isn't the healthiest
thing for me to take that position I'm
not sure you know what I can do is we'll
send you a book I have that's called
women in ministry you know you can take
a look at that see if you get some ideas
from it ed and well does pray God gives
you wisdom it's a tough situation a lot
of churches I've served in they had some
things going on that I didn't always
support and I thought well you know
there when is it Augustine that said you
know we need to have charity in certain
things and be rigid and other things and
have love in all things and so there's
some points of doctrine you know you
don't want to say I'm not going to this
church because they don't agree with me
on 144,000 because there's gonna be
areas where there's disagreement and
then there are some non-negotiable
essentials I do think that these push of
feminism in North America is affecting
the church in an unhealthy way in
society yeah you'll just have to decide
whether that what the steps are to take
on that one pastor also tell you about
the book yeah the book will happy able
to send it to you it or anyone wanting
to learn more about this it's a it's a
good Bible based book that's entitled
God's role for woman in ministry and the
number to call for that is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and again you can ask for the book God's
role for woman ministry and I think
you'll find it an encouragement and
blessing to anyone who reads the book
next caller that we have is Darrell
listening from Florida Darrell welcome
to the program hey Pastor John Ross
pastor Doug Batchelor my dad and I were
discussing Daniel 9:27 and in Daniel
9:27 reads then he shall confirm a
covenant with many for one week now
isn't that the seven-year ministry of
Jesus yes okay and then it says but in
the middle of the week he shall bring an
end to the sacrifice and offering and
that's that's after three and a half
years of Jesus ministry he died on the
cross correct and then the second half
of that three and a half year ministry
that's when Stephen was stoned and then
they the disciples preached to the
Gentiles correct yes okay now why is
that only like three and a half years
because that's still being I mean the
preaching work is still done to this day
well there were three and a half years
it says seventy weeks would be confirmed
or cut off for your people the Jewish
nation they were gonna have the special
privilege of being the ones who would
welcome and proclaim the Messiah so
Jesus was anointed with the Holy Spirit
at his baptism he confirmed the covenant
with the Jewish nation the covenant
being that the savior of the world would
come through the seed of Abraham for
seven years three and a half years in
person he died on the cross the veil in
the temple was ripped he caused the
sacrifice to cease he fulfilled that
sacrifice then he told the the apostles
do not go in the way of the Gentiles not
yet say go first to the lost sheep of
the house of Israel for the next three
and a half years until the stoning of
Stephen exactly three and a half years
later they only preached to Jews then
after the stoning of Stephen Paul is
converted Peter goes to the Gentiles
namely Cornelius and the gospel then you
know spreads everywhere it's just
talking about that there would be this
last week cut off in a special way for
the Jewish nation to hear the gospel
after the Messiah had come and at the
end of that last three and a half years
was there any type of
benchmark or yeah with the stoning of
Stephen now look what happens in Acts
chapter seven when Stephen is stoned
it's a repeat of what happened after
three and a half years of Christ's
ministry Jesus was falsely accused he
was arrested he was tried by the same
court as Stephen he it says there's
clothing that was taken from Christ it
says they laid the clothes at the feet
of Paul when Stephen was stoned
Jesus says Father forgive them Stephen
says Lord lay not this sin to their
charge and the Holy Spirit is poured out
afterward in a special way when Christ
dies on the cross and then the Holy
Spirit is poured out on the Gentiles
after with Cornelius's house after
Stephen dies and so there's so many
parallels between the three-and-a-half
years of Jesus and then the
three-and-a-half years of Stephen we
have a lesson on this we can send you to
well what about
and on the wing of abominations shall be
one who makes desolate what does that
mean well the Roman power that was
responsible for the crucifixion of Jesus
they were though ultimately the ones who
would they were the abomination of
desolation you can read about in Luke
when it says when you see Jerusalem
encompassed with armies then know the
desolation thereof is nigh and Jesus
said those that be in Judea flee into
the mountains the Romans ultimately came
and destroyed the temple so after the
stoning of Stephen there was let me back
up there's a deep prophecy Jesus said
after the disciples showed in the temple
this generation will not pass away till
all these things be fulfilled nailin
namely not one stone being left on
another in the temple a generation of
the Bible is 40 years Jesus made that
prediction in about 30 ad in 70 AD the
Romans destroyed the temple and there
was not one stone left upon another so
that prophecy was remarkably fulfilled
those are two overlapping prophecies
between Daniel 9 and the abomination of
desolation
Jesus refers to the abomination of
desolation in Matthew 24 I've said a
whole lot on this so Pastor Ross we have
a lesson talks about the sanctuary in
the 490 year prophecy we do and the
study guide is called right on time and
it deals with this very important
prophecies you're finding Daniel 9 if
you'd like to receive a copy of this
study guide the number to call is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and again ask to the study guide
called right on time we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks
again that number is 885 six seven four
seven deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
855-578-6767 they started going on me
I'm so tired of my birthday you know so
it stops being special I don't see any
example in the Bible of them doing it
every day one place says they broke
bread from house to house daily that's
not talking about communion it means
they ate together every day they were
having studies it's not talking about
having communion daily okay so some
people have read that in breaking bread
sometimes means simply eating Jesus
broke the bread he multiplied it and he
fed people breaking bread did not always
mean a communion service so when is that
the times of communion well in our
church we generally have our biggest
communion service in the springtime when
you would normally have the Passover it
doesn't have to be on that date and we
usually do do it like three times a year
because some people can't
make it they're traveling and we want to
make sure everybody gets to participate
at least once a year that's what our
philosophy is okay so did
so that's does that include the washing
of feet yep okay
Jesus said if I your Lord and Master
have washed your feet and this is John
you ought to wash one another's feet we
think that that practicing that you know
we we along with your primitive Baptists
and a number of other churches practice
what they go foot washing where we it's
kind of a tender experience someone or
they call it the ordinance of humility
hey thank you Lisa I hope that helps a
little bit and you know some many
churches practice and the Methodist
practice communion quarterly and that'd
be fine
daily the Church of Christ I used to
visit and preach in Church of Christ in
Texas and they would do it every week
and I thought you know it just it's too
too common mm-hmm thank you for your
cole esau next color that we have is del
listening in arkansas del welcome to the
program in jeans my question was kind of
very easy one but if you don't mind I'd
like to give a shout to Jacob the young
man that has a smoking problem I was a
four pack a day smoker and one day I
rolled down the window and I was done
God said this is the giant you're
tackling today and I never desired one
after that and I was four pack today
that's incredible and I've never known
anybody to smoke four packs a day so
that's high smoke sometimes I had too
late at once June it was well yeah yeah
I was bad I couldn't walk 15 feet
without wheezing and I was only 45 years
oh well how long ago was that
you quit January the 19th 2012 praise
God
though what's your question before we
run out of time oh I'm sorry
Nitsa game my questions on the rapture
there are so many different questions on
when it occurs if it even occurs and a
lot of people tap-dance around this and
I I dug you're one of my the big ones
that I like to listen to because you
really do this unbiased and
if you don't mind all hanging up that
way I could put on my headphones oh
really listen and use my Bible if you
state any scripture all right hey we
appreciate that and praise the Lord for
your victory with smoking Dale on the
rapture yeah the idea of rapture means
to be carried away with power to be
caught up the bible does teach in 1st
thessalonians 4 that when the Lord
descends from heaven we will be caught
up to meet him in the air will be
transformed the the dead are resurrected
they are caught up so that is true the
idea that the rapture is a secret is not
correct the Bible tells us the Lord is
going to come with a shout the voice of
the Archangel the Trump of God
some people have read the parable where
Jesus said his coming will be like two
women in the field one has taken one his
left two men in a bed one taken one left
two men in a field one taken one left
the disciples say where are they taken
the Lord and he said where the Eagles
are or the vultures are that's where the
body is or where the body is that's
where the Eagles are so the ones taken
it's talking about they're being taken
away in judgment like when it says the
wicked during the time of the flood the
flood came and took them away people
have misunderstood that parable Jesus is
simply saying there's two kinds of
churches when the Lord comes to women
they're grinding the mill there's two
kinds of people sleeping when Jesus
comes he got that saved and the lost
dead in Christ rise and you got two
kinds of people working in the field
they're doing the master's work some
true some false so they've misunderstood
that I think but yeah it's the Lord is
coming it says like a thief and that
means it's a surprise no man knows the
day or the hour he even told the
apostles in such an hours you think not
the Son of Man is coming but when he
does come let's read second Peter 3 it
tells us the day of the Lord and you can
start at verse 10 the day of the Lord
will come as a thief in the night in
which the heavens pass away with a great
noise and that's not a secret the
elements melt with fervent heat the
earth and the works that are in it are
burned up and it's a scene all these
things will be dissolved what kind of
people aren't we be so
when the Lord comes like a thief
everyone's gonna know it the world is on
fire you know we have a book that deals
with this very subject it's one of my
favorite is called anything but secret
talking about the second coming of
Christ we'll be happy to send us to
anyone who calls and asks and now for
those of you might be wondering about
the second coming of christ the rapture
how does this take place what are the
biblical signs that we have we'll be
happy to send it to you again the book
is called anything but secret in the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven eight
hundred eighty-three five six seven four
seven as for the book anything but
secret
we have Renee listening in Georgia Renee
welcome to the program oh great thanks
for calling thank you about talking in
tongues I understand that in Acts when
they talk to Tom it was to talk to the
different people that was there it is
give the word out to people but I'm kind
of confused one pan filled with the
spirit and talking yeah that's a good
question when it talks in Acts chapter 2
about speaking in tongues it says that
God supernaturally gave the Apostles the
ability to speak in the languages of
these visiting Jews during the Feast of
Pentecost they were coming from all over
the Roman Empire they spoke many
languages
my mother was Jewish but she didn't
speak Hebrew she spoke New York and
you've got you know Jews that were in
Italy they spoke Italian and Jews that
were in Egypt they spoke Egyptian and so
all these Jews from around the world
came to Jerusalem at Pentecost the Lord
poured out the Holy Spirit on the
apostles they then preached the gospel
in the languages of the listening
multitudes and then they in turn took it
back to their countries it was a
brilliant move jesus said in mark 16 you
will speak with other tongues and but
this idea of a prayer language that you
pray in a language you don't understand
you don't really find Jesus the Apostles
doing that prayer is the intelligent
communication of your heart and mind
with the mind of God and for you to just
be babbling words and saying I'm praying
in this special language
that's praying in the spirit that's
nowhere defined in the Bible as prayer
there are three examples of speaking in
tongues in the Bible Acts chapter 2 Acts
chapter 10 Acts chapter 19 in all three
examples there are multiple languages
present and God gives someone the
ability to speak in other languages in
that assembly and they know what they're
saying
it says they spoke the wonderful works
of God or they spoke with tongues and
they prophesied that means they preached
that's relatively new in the last 100
years this idea that the gift of tongues
is an unintelligible language that
nobody understands you don't find that
in the Bible and I have a free gift on
that I'll send you if you just simply
call for it and and who is our caller
Rene about that Rene yeah the number to
call for that is well first of all the
book is called understanding tongues and
it deals with your very question Rene
again this is for anyone who wants to
learn more about it the number to call
for the book is 800 eight three five six
seven four seven and again you can ask
to the book called understanding towns
again one more time
800 eight three five six seven four
seven as to the book called
understanding tongues we've got marked
listening from Michigan mark welcome to
the program a good evening evening mark
night questions about revelation 6 the
Four Horsemen of all the horsemen in
revelation 6 and I heard several takes
on that but I see a lot of parallels
between Deuteronomy 32 and Jeremiah and
Matthew 24
I keep seeing where sword famine
pestilence or death and are used by God
against the people of Israel because
they didn't follow his rules and worship
idols so could it be that their Horsemen
of Revelation 6 is God taking vengeance
on those that did not follow his word
and worship Him well you're correct that
in the seals that you read about there
is some judgment that is coming on
different times of history in the world
now keep in mind when you read the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse the four
are the first four of seven seals that
are being opened says the lamb opened
one seal said come and see and then you
see the first horse and the second or
third or fourth horse but then he opens
fifth seal 6cl seventh seal so the four
horsemen are the first four of seven
seals to understand the four horsemen
you also need to read in Zechariah 1:8
and it talks about these horses four
horses that stand among the myrtle trees
that are going forth to all the kings of
the earth and it sounds like their
judgments horses often represented war
now I know let pastor ross answer this
because he he's written a whole study
series on Revelation they're really
phases in history you want to talk yeah
you got the seven churches you got the
seven seals you got the seven trumpet
and they basically cover the Christian
era a number of scholars are seen in the
first seal he opens it up and there is a
white horse and people seeing that
representing the power of the gospel
going forth in the first century the
church was pure symbolized by the color
white it was victorious speaking about
the spread of Christianity then the next
horse is a red horse and many have
associated the color red with blood or
persecution and that represents a time
period of severe persecution that came
upon the Christian Church right up till
313 with the legalization of
Christianity so that seconals represents
this terrible time of persecution
especially ten years of severe
persecution and then the the next horse
is a black horse and that represents the
dark ages where there was a compromising
of truth a number of pagan ideas found
its way into the Christian Church and
then that leads into the fourth horse
which again is during the time of the
Dark Ages nearing the end of it and
talks about a pale horse symbolizing
death we're really there was in the
established formal church there was a
death to true biblical Christianity and
that's what that's referring to there
also there was a bubonic plague came
during that time one of the greatest
one-third of Europe I think died during
that time you know friends it's probably
not fair I see a few people were
standing by we did not get to you and
hope you give us another chance next
week
first we thought we had no calls and
then folks lined up and we appreciate
your calling and if you've been blessed
by this program you know we we don't say
much about it during the broadcast but I
will mention at the end we are entirely
supported by listeners if you've been
encouraged or edified we just pray the
Holy Spirit will touch some of you to
say you know I want to help keep this
program on the air and get us on more
stations just go to the amazing facts
website and you'll see a little button
that I hope the buttons there click and
donate keep us on the air sharing the
good news and while you're there take
advantage of all the wonderful things at
amazing facts dot o-r-g god bless
listening friends it's a joy studying
the word with you by His grace we'll get
together and talk about the truth next
week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
terror attacks natural disasters
political instability and global
economic meltdown these are the images
people generally associate with the
tribulation and the day of the Lord but
did you know the Bible speaks about
another day of the Lord just before the
great Judgment Day
amazingly imprinted on the very fabric
of time itself is a 24-hour period
called the Sabbath that was meant to
forever be a time of restoration for
every human being a day the entire world
is largely forgotten you'll be surprised
to learn how this special day of the
Lord
factors into last day prophecies such as
the mark of the beast the seal of God
and the great final tribulation it's all
contained in this new eye-opening DVD
series called the last day of prophecy
to order call 800 538 7 to 75 or visit a
book store calm
what if you could know the future
what would you do what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past Alexander the Great becomes
king when he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy
a hundred and fifty years in advance
Cyrus had been named wrong was violent
they were ruthless they were determined
the Gospel writers see his death as a
fulfillment of salvation this intriguing
documentary hosted by Pastor Doug
Batchelor explores the most striking
Bible prophecies that have been
dramatically fulfilled throughout
history kingdoms in time get your copy
today available now on DVD blu-ray or
USB for more information visit kingdoms
in time.com
[Music]
for over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air so the
blessings you've received can be shared
with others to find out more about
becoming a ministry partner please visit
our website to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 may sing facts o RG